年末の寒くて寂しい一人の夜彼は今日もパソコンに向かってカタカタカタカタと文章を
打った
car
tan
わー
まだ大丈夫まだ大丈夫だ大丈夫だよまあ大丈夫こねーちゃん肇社長です
いよいよ今年も本当に終わりの時期に来たんですけどもそれと同時に僕の卒業論文の
締め切りも迫ってきているわけでございます
まだまにゃま the money はまーだパンチ江華島欄でやってほしい山ねーよ
全然まだ大丈夫なんてもうちょっと期間はあるんですけども
文字数的にももう超えてます it 提出をできるんですけども今か v 修正とかも
ずっとコーナーをすべきところとかオチョチョやってるんでもうねもう本当に爪の部分
は誰だねぇ
焦りますあのここまで来るとちょっとねやっぱりねやっておかなきゃいけないっていう
感じが強くてねなかなかでちょっと来てがも今年でて終わらせるよ絶対年内にはもう方
ずにするんでもうちょっともうちょっともう何スネアの
もう動画撮ってる余裕はちょっとない
出ちゃうぞになど取って余裕がないと言ってはうそになるがあの動画撮ってる時間が
あったら卒業論文書いた方がいい感じですので今日はちょっと卒業論文をやりますね
ごめんなさい
と見せかけてもうこのタイミングでしかないでしょ質問コーナーリクエストコーナー
ほリクエストコーナー僕にコーヒー体育のとか中洲でも最後でてほしいことがたら各
動画はこうだねぇ
入ってゆけこの動画のコメントなんで僕にやってほしいことと金子してほしいことを気
になることを質問したいこととかねお山でお店はなんでもいいんでも何でも買えちゃっ
てくださいってそれをもとにして僕が動画を作るかもしれません
クリアーもう一平
ずつ潰していくからな絶対絶命的な状況じゃないから確実に確実に一歩ずつ歩いていき
ますよあそうだあのその後なぁまだ質問コーナーまだて言われるんですけども
もうね今日はバスと言いますよ1が2-1月の3日までに渡します水と地に出せばいい
んですけども一つ5忙しくて分からないではもう
俺だねちょっと僕次第なんですけども1月の3日までには
だします
多分
出せなかったらこれが3日くらいちょっと目安に考えててくれればいいんだよね
もう適当なコメント電気はもうああいう女をそれねいいな事書いちゃってくださいそれ
をねぇまず言いたかった
ことしは本当にねあとたくさんの方に支えられた年でした
本当にいつも応援して下さる皆さん
ありがとうございますリズ月3日までにはやるので良かったら見たらコメントぜひぜひ
書いちゃってください今年はもう本当に支えられてるんです皆さんに支えられている分
ですね僕は今目の前の卒論をね
倒さなきゃいけないんですけどお正月からも質問コーナーしていくスタイルでちょっと
来年は1分前の皆さんのコメントお待ちしております梅雨なんですけどはず
社長2のセカンドチャンネルの方がですねもうすぐチャンネル登録者が100万人いく
んだよかったらそちらもよろしくお願いしますゲーム実況動画とかラフな頭が告知動画
ラグすぎた[ __ ]動画とかもあるんでよかったらそちらのチャンネル登録お待ちしており
ますでは皆さんのコメントを交えつつ僕は今夜も地獄のように卒論励みますじゃん